war of words among two reported targets
of the Muller probe earlier today the
daily caller reported of an early copy
of a book written by author jerome corsi
now in this book course he claims that
he testified the mother's grand jury
that just one month before the 2016
election Trump confidant Roger stone
asked him to contact Julian Assange
about releasing Podesta's John Podesta Z
mails now course he claims this was
because stone had advanced knowledge of
the release of those infamous Access
Hollywood tape that knowledge that he
knew about that and advanced knowledge
of the emails themselves course II was
asked about this earlier tonight on our
own Tucker Carlson
this is a political winch HUD because I
did not have a contact with Assange but
yet had figured out that Assange had
Podesta's emails and I figured out and
told Roger stone and told many people in
August and it just happened that I was
right I did figure it out and I connect
the dots and this time I happened to be
right you just won't believe that I
figured it out Roger stone is disputing
some of course these other claims and he
has a lot to say he joins us now in an
exclusive interview to tell us what is
going on here Roger it's good to see you
tonight I know you watched what mr.
korsky said on Tucker Carlson show a lot
of folks watching you know they think of
the Muller probe and like nefarious
Russian plots and they here you know is
Assange is name the Ecuadorian Embassy
they don't know who jerome corsi is and
they kind of know who you are but
simplify this for us so our listeners
know what they need to know to
understand the current state of affairs
in this investigation as it as it
pertains to you well first of all laura
thank you for having me because my own
show it Infowars is so heavily censored
to deny me a forum to have a chance to
defend myself I'm very grateful for the
chance to be here this is really simple
it shows what happens when you hotbox a
72 year old man for 40 hours as the
Muller interrogators did quite clearly I
made it very clear that on
his 21st I posted a tweet that said the
Podesta's time in the barrel will come I
meant that public scrutiny of the
Podesta's Russian business interests as
I had been briefed about by Gerry course
II would be in the media now Gerry Corsi
has been browbeat into claiming that
that was some kind of a cover story and
because I was taking heat for that tweet
but that's not even logical Laura
because my tweet wasn't controversial
until six weeks later when Julian
Assange published John Podesta's email
so I had no advance notice that his
emails would be stolen or that they
would be published and then the
secondary claim that I knew about the
Billy Bush NBC tape in advance and that
I asked Jerry Corsi to contact Julian
Assange to ask Assange to move up or
move back his his data dump to distract
attention from that that's a fairy tale
that's just whole cloth I learned about
it at four o'clock in the afternoon like
every other American I was actually on
the street in Manhattan and Roger
there was no sad that he's been
pressured this way Roger there's a bear
false witness xed evidence or email
evidence regarding the Billy Bush claim
and nothing nothing definitive about the
other claim about advanced knowledge is
this and what there's just one email
from you to Corsi from July 25th of 2016
we'll just put it up on the screen then
this is from the draft court papers get
to us guess Assange at the Ecuadorian
Embassy in London and get the pending
WikiLeaks emails that's what you've
referenced several times and just once
again why doesn't that look bad
well there's an important back story
because hours before that I was
forwarded an email by James Rosen of Fox
that had been sent to me by Charles or
tell one of the very best researchers
and investigators in the country and
Rosen had gotten a tip that the
disclosures were going to be about the
Clinton Foundation like every Politico
like every political reporter
America I was curious about what Assange
had the bottom of line of this law is
very clear nothing we've learned in the
last 72 hours shows that there was any
collusion between the Russian state and
Donald Trump's campaign $2,000,000
pardon me twenty million dollars and two
years in there's still no evidence of
any such Russian collusion well not
according to DNA which Roger not
according to David SiC alene who and
this is from today on CNN who made a
contrary claim let's watch well I think
again this is more evidence of an
ongoing conspiracy or collusion between
high-ranking Trump campaign officials
and WikiLeaks and Julian Assange and the
stolen emails you can see that he's not
only directing jerome corsi to get
information about forget the copies of
the emails or get information about them
he reports back to Roger stone on August
2nd your response to him some of it
you've covered when did politicize what
did political gossip become criminalized
everybody in America wanted to know
after Assange teased these emails on CNN
in June and then on Fox in August what
exactly it was that he had but there is
no flow of information I received no
emails and pass no emails on to Donald
Trump or the Trump campaign that's just
a fairy tale but let's face it the
entire Russian collusion delusion is
meant to distract us from the fact that
the Obama administration the Obama NSA
the Obama FBI were using illegal
unconstitutional FISA warrants to spy on
Donald Trump's campaign and we're using
the FBI to infiltrate Donald Trump's
campaign that plus uranium one there's a
great need to distract from all of those
things so we point to Donald Trump and
the phony Russian collusion which just
doesn't exist have you been offered a
deal by the special counsel most
certainly not and there's no
circumstance under whatsoever that I
would bear false witness against the
president I am being persecuted because
I supported Donald Trump for president
and because I helped
defeat Hillary Clinton and for no other
reason Roger stone thank you so much for
joining us tonight we really appreciate
it